pour approfondir ce sujet assez complet
j'ai avec moi sylvie lavallée aller
sexologue clinicienne et
psychothérapeute
bonsoir madame la vallée bonsoir on
vient l'entendre dans le reportage la
docteur moreau qui doutent qu'une pilule
puissent venir régler le manque de désir
sexuel chez les femmes utilisent ça peut
pas tout régler
une pilule c'est on a l'impression que
ça peut être miraculeux parce que ça
nous déresponsabilise je pense et je
n'ai pas besoin de réfléchir et sa règle
tout dans le désir féminin ce qui est
une bonne chose que les chercheurs aient
enfin voulu sonder les choses au niveau
des femmes parce que ça se fait beaucoup
chez les hommes ils ont plein d'options
que les femmes on attend on a tendance à
plus sexistes comme recherche niveau-là
ce une bonne nouvelle
oui c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que
il ya une option ça veut pas dire que
c'est la solution mais c'est une option
maintenant moi ce qui m'encourage c'est
que ça va peut-être incité des femmes à
aborder ce sujet là avec leur médecin
qui est un sujet très tabou hautement
censurées on peut parler de la fatigue
insomnie la surcharge de main et
problèmes gastriques de dos mais la
libido le désir l'excitation l'orgasme
son ne parle pas alors au moins l'oeil
vont pouvoir aborder le sujet pour
essayer de chercher des solutions un
traitement peut-être en avait conclu
s'allier avec des médecins pour qui un
traitement sexothérapie aussi bon et
quand on parle de panne de désir si
seulement il dit qu'est-ce que si vous
avez le désir sexuel oui de quoi on
parle exactement on parle de il n'ya pas
du d2 fantasmatique d'inspiration la
capacité d'anticiper ya rien il ya un
vide mentale la personne ne plus le bout
et ne se sent pas capable d'avoir le
goût il ya beaucoup de femmes que ça
touche énormément de femmes de tous
groupes d'âge confondues on sait en ex
beaucoup sur les femmes pré ménopausées
ménopause ou post ménopausées mais c'est
petit chez une femme dans vingtaine dans
la trentaine d'ailleurs dans les études
la moyenne d'âge et 36 ans mais c'est à
cet âge là conseillé à peu près tout ce
qu'on aime
carrière donc un essoufflement puis ou
si peut-être bon un épuisement dans la
relation aussi parce que il n'y a pas de
tests sanguins kit esse le sentiment
amoureux
l'intérêt de l'autre le choix de
partenaires et pas connaître mon
partenaire ce que je le choisis encore
et c'est ça que ça soulève la panne de
désir donc une panne avait au moins
pendant 3 mois frein c'est pas que
passager parce que ça concerne tout le
monde le désir c'est comme la bourse
fluctuent ça change
mais quand ça s'installe et ses
permanents et ses troubles un sac une
détresse pour la femme pour l'autre
aussi beaucoup de frustration que l'on
sent qu'on est dans un cercle vicieux
que plus rien de l'issue parce qu on
arrête tout on fait plus rien n'y a pas
de solution on abdique et là c'est
problématique
alors comment fonctionnerait cette
pilule parce que on la compare au viagra
ont dit sylvia graff féminin mais est ce
que ça peut agir sur le fil il peut agir
sur le désir ce qu'ils disent et agit
sur la sérotonine parce que c'est un
comprimé qui était à l'étude le
flibanserin la molécule a été testée à
la base comme antidépresseur et dans les
groupes de recherche se sont rendus
compte qu'il y avait apparemment un
appétit un peu plus du rendez vous de la
sexualité alors ça a eu lui mais
beaucoup de lumière on a changé
l'orientation de la médication mais au
niveau de la sérotonine qui est
l'hormone rumeurs qui fluctuent aussi
dépendamment si on sent bien ou moins
bien donc s'agit un peu plus là dessus
que sur l'aspect plus mécanique dans de
créer un peu plus un afflux de saint
denis par sensibilité dans les organes
donc ça joue pas sur la mécanique comme
pour moins sur la mécanique est ce que
évidemment il ya des restrictions pour
les femmes qui ont utilisé cette pilule
par exemple sur l'alcool sur des choses
comme ça et elles vont devoir
l'apprendre à long terme
est ce que les femmes vont vouloir
rapidement terminant se soumettre à ça
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent qui est
en jeu et évidemment quand on pense aux
pharmaceutiques
il ya de payer pour le comprimé déjà on
peut être qu'elle se rende j'ai pas
envie de payer pour quelque chose qui
s'en mettent naturel en plus comme un
contraceptif oral faut que je me dise
finale prendra tous les jours où un
antidépresseur mais si elles se disent
je suis moins dans le précipice je suis
un kilomètre du précipice
je suis moins troublée de ma sexualité
gerland qui je peux peut-être avoir
confiance et je pense que des femmes qui
ont besoin d'avoir certain succès quand
ça va pas bien on a envie de penser ou
de croire que ça pourrait bien aller et
ça vaut peut-être la peine zaba chevet
restreinte sur la consommation d'alcool
et je vais même discipline et à la
prendre
est-ce que ça va durer une autre chose
je pense bas risque au canada aussi ça
c'est une autre question
un suivi maintenant il ya les peaux
question merci beaucoup merci